[Music]
hello everyone
in this video we are going to start with
the new chapter on torsion
now torsion is a chapter which almost
all of you
must have covered in your undergraduate
mechanics of solids or mechanics of
materials class
so as part of this advanced mechanics of
solids the new thing that we are going
to address
is torsion of non-circular cross
sections
so that's making it much more general
than what you have already studied
under torsion so now
with that concern we look at
this particular diagram where we have
this shaft or beam and you can
clearly see that the cross section over
here is very much
non-circular okay uh
now uh we'll also see
how uh this more general formulation
will uh we can specialize it to the
uh to to the simple things which you had
studied
in the context of torsion of a circular
cross section
now what we have over here
is that this shaft or beam it is being
subjected to this
torque at this end and
an equal and opposite torque at the
other end now it is extremely important
to note
uh although i'm sure you you you already
know this from your undergraduate
studies that
when you're looking at this from this
end this torque is looking like
anti-clockwise now if you're looking at
this very shaft from the other end it'll
again this particular thing which is now
clockwise from this side
that will look anti-clockwise okay so
that thing must be very very clear and
it's important
now as we have done in the previous
theories
we started out with a kinematical
hypothesis and that's exactly the same
thing that we are going to do
now uh all that we are going to write
uh or everything that we're going to
write will be referred
uh to a particular cross section okay so
let me consider this cross section here
[Music]
so i have slightly made it bigger in
order to make it clearer
and let me write out the x-axis and the
y-axis here
so it's something like this
but very important note is that the
x-axis the the origin of the upper
xyz axis there at the other end
and it is this end that i'm talking over
here in fact it it could be any
particular or any any
cross section within the within the
length of the beam
okay uh
let me adjust that a bit
okay
so that's my x-axis that's my y-axis
now under the action of this torque
any point within this cross-section
it will undergo certain displacement
and as part of our kinematical
hypothesis we would like to
represent that displacement okay so
suppose we have a point here in the
undeformed configuration that is
before the torque has been applied now
as it as a result of the application of
the talk
you can understand that this point may
travel to this point
okay now uh what we are going to do
as part of our formulation is that we
are going to consider such displacements
to be very small
okay so everything that we are going to
write will be within the purview of
small displacements
okay so uh so small strains infestable
strains that's what we are
we're going to be concerned with okay so
even this kind of a displacement that i
have shown for the purpose of clarity is
quite
exaggerated actually now
uh what i'll say is
[Music]
this this thing
this is my r
and
this is my theta and
uh this r theta it represents
the coordinate of this
yellow colored point in the undeformed
configuration
so in the deform configuration we can
we can understand that
there will be a bit of an angular
displacement
and that will be given by
uh so this small angle over here that
is that i'll call as beta
now question is what is this
displacement
in terms of u v and w
okay so let us discuss that in detail
now in order to to to understand the
geometry
here what we can do is uh
we can draw this line and we can zoom
into it
okay let us zoom into it a little bit so
this is uh
this is the this is the same line that i
have drawn over here
and uh
[Music]
because i have considered this angle
beta to be small
so this length it is approximately
this is approximately equal to r
beta it is not perfectly equal to our
beta but approximately r beta
especially this is especially true if
beta is small
so can we represent this
uh the the the component of this
in the x direction what i mean to say is
what is this
what is this horizontal displacement
what is this vertical displacement
okay so
this u can we not
write it as r beta
okay so what is this angle so you have
to understand
that
this is theta uh
this is 90 degree minus theta
um sorry this is 90 degrees so this is
90 degrees minus theta
so this is theta okay so
this is theta so this
this particular part that will be given
by
sine theta but of course with a negative
sign
similarly the displacement along the y
direction
that will be given by this vertical
dashed line
and that will be given by our
beta cos theta
now you please note that what is this
r sine theta that r sine theta
is it not simply y
this is nothing but minus y beta
similarly this r cos theta over here
that is
simply x so this becomes x beta
what about w
so this is the part uh so when we start
thinking about w
it is the out of plane displacement okay
that we have to understand physically
or geometrically now when we were
talking about
uh torsion with respect uh for a
for a shaft with circular cross section
in our undergraduate days then uh
we knew that the out of plane
displacement of that circular shaft
was zero and that is the primary
difference that we have
with for a non-circular cross section
that this out of plane displacement is
not going to be zero
all right so this non-zero thing
that will be represented that will
represent
by this graduated kappa and
this kappa is going to be a function of
only x and y
okay now you can start thinking about it
in terms of uh plain strain conditions
but please be very careful when you
before you leave
leave to any any conclusion regarding
the analogy with
uh regarding the plane strain condition
okay so please be very very careful
furthermore one very important thing
which will say is that
the rate of twist the rate of twist is
referred to this end what is the
twist that is induced by this torsion
at a certain distance from from it okay
so
refer to this end how much
any particular cross section that we may
consider along the length
that has twisted twisted means turned
around
okay so this is this is a this kind of
displacement is a result
of the twist so how much is the twist so
we
represent uh that rate of twist or the
twist
uh per unit length up as
alpha okay so
[Music]
so we say rate but it is it has nothing
to do with time
okay it is the rate of twist per unit
length
so that is that is given by this alpha
and that is
this d of
the beta d z
okay so you can understand that
uh when
we are at z equal to zero that
is at this end
then uh this beta
that is equal to zero
[Music]
and when we are at this end we have the
maximum
value of that but this alpha itself that
is not changing that is a
that is a constant along this length
so uh what we have just said regarding
this
alpha is somewhat reminiscent of what
you had studied
uh in the context of circular cross
section also
okay so let me write this down
so at
z equal to 0
we have beta equal to zero
and at z equal to
uh so
or we can say that at any at any generic
general set
uh
at any general z our
beta is equal to alpha z
okay now if this is so
if this beta is a like alpha z then we
can come to this
expression and write this as minus
alpha y z similarly this can be written
as
alpha x z
later on what we are going to do is to
also represent
this deformation represented by the
kappa in terms
of this alpha also but but but that's
for later
okay so right now what we want to do is
as part of our kinematical hypothesis so
see
all these things that you have discussed
this is part of our kinematical
hypothesis so what we want to do next
is to write down the various values of
the strings
okay so epsilon xx
that is equal to del u del x
and just take a look here the u is
completely independent of x
okay this alpha is a constant y and z
is certainly independent of x so del u
del x
is equal to zero
epsilon y y that is equal to
del v del y let's check
v here alpha is a constant x and z are
independent of y
so del v del y is equal to zero
next epsilon z z
that is del w del z
but we have already taken as part of our
kinematical hypothesis
that w is equal to kappa and kappa is a
pure function of
x and y that is it is independent of z
so w is independent of z
so del w del z is equal to zero
next for epsilon x y
we have half del u del y
plus del p
del x
let's see what happens to it so del u
del y
is minus alpha z
this is minus alpha z
[Music]
next v so we need the del v del x
so for that we have alpha z
plus alpha z so this also
is zero next
epsilon y z
we have del v del z
plus del w del y
well v is alpha exit
so del v del z is nothing but alpha x
[Music]
plus you see this w is a function
of uh through through its representation
in terms of
kappa it is a function of x and y but
you don't know its exact form
okay so we have to keep it as it is
the only thing that we can do it do here
is to write it in terms of the kappa
and just leave it like this next
for epsilon zx we have half
del w del x plus
del u del z so let me
first write this del u del z
del u del z is minus alpha y
minus alpha y plus del w del x that
gives me
del kappa del
x so the only uh non-zero components of
the strings
of the infinitesimal strains are this
epsilon y z
and epsilon zx okay
so next what i'm going to do
is exactly so the overall overall
formulation here is following exactly
what we had done in our previous
chapters
except that as a result of the special
considerations associated with
distortion
and the kinematical hypothesis
associated there with
uh we are getting different uh
uh so the so the non-zero components of
the strains have turned out to be
uh in for the epsilon why is it in the
synthetics unlike before
uh but but uh but the strategy remains
same
so what we are going to do next is to
use the virtual work equation
so that we can ultimately arrive at the
governing equations
and boundary conditions okay so
let me go to the new page and use the
virtual work equation
[Music]
so first of all i have this term sigma i
j del epsilon i j
d v and that is equal to
t i del u i
d a and again you note that i am
disregarding the body forces here
so first of all i'll consider the left
hand side
so i have this
sigma i j del epsilon i j
d v now
please note that there will be no
contribution
associated with the terms involving the
sigma xx the sigma yy
and the sigma zz because we have already
found in the previous speech that
epsilon xx epsilon yy
and epsilon z are zero okay
furthermore uh the epsilon xy is also
zero so there will be no contribution
from the term involving the sigma xy
but we will have contributions from
uh from the terms with the subscripts y
z and zx
and because there will be two such terms
for those
uh from the y z and the z y
as well as from the zx and xz what we
are going to end up with
is uh is basically this
that we'll have twice sigma
or sigma yz twice sigma yz
del epsilon yz
plus twice sigma zx
del epsilon x
this is over the entire volume and
what we can do is we can uh we can
rewrite this
in that you know volume term as
uh as the area multiplied by the length
okay so first we are going to integrate
over a particular cross section and then
integrate over the entire length and
because there is no variation along the
length
so what will basically happen is that
the
will have
will have the length uh the l coming out
of the
integration okay so uh
we'll also take this twice out
furthermore you note that this sigma yz
that can be written as twice
g epsilon y z
okay uh that is from the constitutive
relation
so overall what we are going to have is
four
epsilon y z
del epsilon y z
plus uh we'll also have twice g epsilon
zx here
so that four also has gone out
this is epsilon zx del epsilon
zx
[Music]
so this is integration with respect to
the entire area and what we have
what we'll do is we'll we should not
forget this
g that has come out and
the length has also come out of this
okay so basically what we have done
is to do an integration with respect to
the area and then another integration
with respect to dz
but everything else here is independent
of z
so uh so that integration with
with respect to d z that is just alone
and that just contributes
an l okay uh so we have done these kinds
of things
many times earlier i'm not going to the
details of that
all right now we have this 4g
l now it's time to substitute these um
the expressions of this epsilon yz and
epsilon zx from what we had obtained in
the previous page
so let's take a look here uh epsilon y z
is this thing
uh half of alpha x plus del kappa
del y
so half of alpha x plus
del kappa del y
multiplied by so now we have this
x delta alpha
plus del
delta kappa
del y
plus for the epsilon zx we have
minus alpha y plus del kappa del
x
minus alpha y plus
del kappa del x
multiplied by this del of epsilon zx
that is minus
y del alpha plus
del delta kappa
del x and of course i'll have a half
over here
this is within the integration with
respect to the entire
cross-sectional area
so you can see now and there will be a
half over here also there will be a half
over here also
i'll correct that
so this 4 will cancel with this half
times half
and what i'll do over here is to
multiply this term
uh so i'll expand this out a little bit
okay
so
[Music]
just make a little space for myself here
so i have alpha x plus del
gamma del y
that multiplied by this
x then i'll have a delta alpha
and over here also i'll have a similar
kind of term
involving the delta alpha so
i have this minus alpha y
plus del copper delta
x multiplied
by this minus y
and this entire thing
so maybe i should clear write that a bit
more clearly
uh i think i'll just write this with an
integration like this with a
delta alpha here
okay let me not make this an entire
integration
within a square bracket okay and
uh here i have mistracting that
gl so i'll just put that in
i'll also have another term
gl so this time i'm going to multiply
this
with this
so i have alpha x plus del
copper del y
del delta kappa
till y
and let me just adjust that a little bit
plus this term minus
alpha plus del kappa del x
multiplied by this del delta
kappa del x
and
so there we have it here okay
now uh what we are going to do
um is to try to manipulate this thing a
little bit
uh taking lessons from what we had
already done in the previous two
chapters on classical plate theory and
the focus one common plate theory
the motivation here is to arrive at
at an equation which will only involve
or at least terms which will involve uh
this delta kappa alone without any
any any of these derivatives okay so
let's see if we can do that
so what i'll do is i'll copy this entire
line
and copy this entire line and go to the
next page
[Music]
okay
so this first term that can be slightly
simplified
so we have this alpha
x square and then
alpha y squared
and then we have this
alpha x
del copper del y
minus
um
[Music]
so this alpha shouldn't be here
minus y del
kappa del x
okay next
from here what i'll do is
i will take this del del y uh
out of uh out of this thing so so that
the alpha x plus
del kappa del y becomes within this del
del y
[Music]
is something like this
together with this
delta kappa
and then i'll have to compensate for
this
for this extra term that i have
introduced here
by subtracting this down
next for this term i'll do the exact
same thing
and then compensate
i believe i have missed one term over
here
so this particular thing
uh it was uh its origin was here so we i
had
minus alpha y over here instead of
just the alpha so i'll make a correction
this was minus alpha y
consequently i'll have a minus alpha y
over here
[Music]
and here also i'll have a minus alpha y
sorry about that
and here also
[Music]
all right
so overall let's see what we are
obtaining here
um this thing whatever we could do we
have done
uh over here uh
you see this entire combination
this del del x of something plus del del
y of something
that can be rewritten uh
using the greens theorem as we had done
in the case of
uh so i'll not repeat this line over
here
instead i'll just copy it from the
previous thing
so there it is exactly the same as the
previous line
here as i was saying this del del x of
something plus del del y of something
for that i will utilize the greens
theorem
[Music]
to to write that as
uh in terms of the nx and the
ny uh but
uh i think it will be just uh easier
if i if i just postpone writing that
for now i'll just club them together uh
to be manipulated later
okay so it's something like this
that i have this
so let me just copy this thing
i'll have this term
and i'll have this done
and this should be a plus in between
so this entire thing
is where i'm going to use uh our greens
theorem later on
and the terms that we are left with are
there here okay so
i take this minus and this minus out uh
so i'll be left with
[Music]
let me just write that down so del del
x minus alpha y
plus del copper del x
plus del del y
alpha x plus del kappa
del y so again i have written this term
first
here and this term here second
okay and there is a delta
kappa sitting outside and this entire
integration is with respect to
a so overall as i had already mentioned
uh structurally what we are doing uh in
terms of our
mathematical derivation is exactly the
same as before the terms just look
different because we are dealing with
torsion that's all there is to it okay
but let us not forget that what we have
managed to achieve here
is some manipulation associated with
just the left hand side of the virtual
work equation
the right hand side is still left okay
so what is the right hand side
well let me go to the next page here
the right hand side
[Music]
is this ti delta ui
da now
you see this is the this is the
externally applied
traction but what do we have really in
terms of the external loading it is the
torsion the actual torque
so how can we
represent this ti delta ui uh
in terms of the torque and uh and the
twist
that is uh that the shaft is undergoing
so uh consider this let me give you the
answer and then ask you to think about
it
is it not something like this that we
have the torque
and the associated uh deflection that it
induces which is just an
angle so uh
and you see the the unit here is
actually uh
i mean it will match with whatever we
have written over here
okay now uh
it perhaps makes sense
to uh
well uh let me not get ahead of myself
so it's something like this that
uh
we would very much like to uh
to understand to to understand this
thing uh
in terms of this thing so can we not
perhaps
think of this torque
like some kind of a uh
has been contributed by some kind of a
force okay so this is
i'm trying to draw an analogy here that
if you have
some kind of a cross section like this
and you have a dot being applied like
this
then can you not think of this torque
as some force okay so perhaps you you
considered
a point here and you considered a little
force here
then can you not think of this dog as
being generated by a series of such
forces
uh where the moment arm would be given
by this distance okay so suppose we
calculate this torque
about the about the origin
then
[Music]
we have this r times this f where this f
is uh well can think of it in terms of
t by r okay
now it is extremely important to note
that
this r here is not a constant this r
will vary
as this orange colored line it varies
over the entire periphery which means
meaning to say that this r here is a
function of
theta okay which makes sense of course
so overall that entire thing is what is
going to give us
uh this kind of a term but it's also
important to note
that
uh this thing that we that we have over
here
um can we
perhaps write this
can you perhaps write this okay so let
me take you to the first page
you see this beta is
in terms of this alpha z so
uh can we perhaps think of
this as t
times l
delta alpha so what am i doing over here
you see um
[Music]
what what has actually gone on over here
you can try to think of it like this
that the rhs
uh this is one way of thinking
uh that we have something like d
now t delta beta
evaluated at that equal to l
minus t times
delta beta evaluated at z equal to zero
then this thing is like
t delta beta but
[Music]
this is like this boundary terms
so that we can rewrite this thing in
terms of an integration
like this t
d delta beta
d z
dz integration 0 to l
so that this
this thing inside the integration that
can be
rewritten as t delta of
d beta dz dz
and this is like so d beta dz
is nothing but alpha and now you see
this
alpha is very much independent of z so
that overall what we'll have
is t delta alpha
integration 0 to l
that gives me this thing okay so that's
how
i like to think of going from here to
here
so if you can try to i mean maybe you
can try to come up with
a different sort of interpretation okay
now
uh the fact remains that we do have this
tl
delta alpha on the right hand side now
uh so let me just complete this
what i was discussing here so this is
like a t by r
and this r here is
is a function of theta okay just to
complete that picture
okay now what we want to do is of course
uh take this lhs equal to rhs
and see what kind of terms uh we'll get
okay so what i'll do is
i'll take this entire thing
maybe make it a little bit smaller so
that it becomes a little bit more
visually manageable
okay and on the right hand side
i have this tl delta alpha
all right so you see
uh
on the right hand side we have a term
involving the delta alpha
okay so what we plan to do now see this
is basically the virtual work equation
okay and from this virtual work equation
we want to extract
the boundary conditions and uh
and the governing equations and whatever
so uh on the right hand side we have
this delta alpha on the left hand side
we have this delta alpha
now you may be a little bit disheartened
by the fact that this delta alpha is
sitting within this integration and on
the right hand side it is just sitting
without the integration
okay but and there is no reason to feel
this hardened because
uh you said this delta alpha uh
i mean it might as well be going outside
this integration because
uh over this integration i mean this is
this is an integration over the
xy domain and this alpha is very much
independent of x and y
okay so it can it can very well come out
of this integration so it's like g alpha
delta
now gl delta alpha this entire term so
uh if you want to equate so all that you
have to do is
uh we can extract this thing and utilize
it with this
here okay so that's exactly what we are
going to do
but let us not forget that we have still
not simplified this term
okay so we would very much like to
utilize
our uh our greens theorem
to to simplify this and represent this
in terms of an integration over the
periphery so let's do that
okay so
i can copy this
plus gl
this thing
minus alpha y plus
del kappa del x
delta copper and
x plus this thing
within the curly bracket alpha x
plus del kappa del y
delta kappa
and y
and this entire thing
will be will be just the cyclic integral
okay so this integration which is over
the entire domain here
has now become an integration over the
entire periphery not over the entire
domain a
okay so this is the s variable
representing
the uh variable tracking the periphery
of the
of the cross section this term however
will remain as it is
and so also the right right-hand sector
okay so now we are ready to extract the
different parts
out of it so the first thing is we are
going to
so let me write it therefore here
okay so
gl integration
over the entire domain this thing
alpha x square plus y square
sorry about that alpha times x square
plus y square
plus x del kappa
del y minus y
then kappa del x
d a that is going to be equal to
l so you see what i have done here is to
basically first take this delta alpha
outside and then equate that term with
the term on the right hand side which
also has this
coefficient of you know of this delta
alpha
okay next we are going to consider
the term on the left hand side which has
this delta kappa
and you please note that on the right
hand side i don't have any term
involving delta kappa okay there is no
integration term involving the delta
in fact there is no other term involving
the delta kappa
so all that i have to do is to consider
just this just whatever is present
inside here and i can write that down
so del del x
minus alpha plus
del kappa del x
plus del del y
of alpha x plus del kappa
del y you see this is a nice equation
because you see here the alpha is very
much independent of x
and y is independent of x which means
that del del x of minus alpha y
is just 0. similarly here
alpha is independent of y and x is
certainly independent of y
so del del y of alpha x that term is
going to be 0
so overall what i'll end up with here is
del square kappa
del x square plus del square
kappa del y square that is equal to zero
okay and finally what i will be left
with
is just this term okay just this term
and again you note that uh
okay so this is the this is the boundary
term
okay okay so uh
there's a little trick involved here uh
you may be tempted to write or extract
out of this term uh something like
an either or statement okay so perhaps
you'd um you you take this delta cup
common here so you'd be left with this
all these terms involving the nx and
ny and then perhaps you would be writing
either that term involving the nx
and y is equal to zero or kappa is
specified
because you have this delta kappa but
you please note
that i mean
saying a thing or considering the
possibility
of kappa being specified really doesn't
make any sense
because kappa is the out of plane
displacement
of the shaft okay and that
is never going to be specified to us
okay so let me just take a look at the
figure that we have drawn initially
you see the copper represents is just
the w
okay so that is something very much not
known to us
okay and for a situation like this you
will never expect
that that that kappa the w the out of
plane displacement
will be specified to us okay so
for all intents and purposes what we can
do
considering this term is to simply say
that
this term involving the nx and ny that
is directly
that is going to be the one with the
zero
okay so uh
so let's see
um yeah i can write it here
minus alpha y plus
del kappa del x
multiplied by n x
plus alpha x plus
del kappa del y
multiplied by n y
that thing is going to be zero
on the boundary on the boundary of the
cross section okay
[Music]
so there is a subtle logic involved here
so
what are the things that we are
obtaining we are obtaining one governing
differential equation
involving this kappa we are obtaining
one uh one equation which is valid over
the boundary so that is like our bounded
boundary condition and please note that
that does involve
this kappa and we are also obtaining
this extra equation which sort of
connects
our applied load t
to to this kappa okay so we don't have
the kappa here but in this term we
certainly have the presence of this
kappa and it is a big sigh
of relief for us that we do have such an
equation
otherwise you see what would have
happened is that in this equation which
we are referring to as the governing
equation
we do not have the presence of this t
and and in this
equation which we are referring to as
the boundary condition there also the t
is not present so how can it be that we
are
we are obtaining a framework for solving
for the out of plane displacement
represented by this kappa
but in this entire business the
influence of
the applied load which is actually
bringing about the twist
or the torsion that is not present that
would have been absolutely
uh meaningless so if if we had obtained
an equation which was just
these two equations and not and we did
not have the presence of this equation
then it would have been really really
troublesome for us
okay because then we have completely
lost the connection
between the source of all our deflection
which is the torsion
and the deflection itself okay so so
considering these three equations
together we are at least uh
happy that uh okay
we have a source of the deflection and
we have
a connection between the deflection and
this and the source
and we also have a separate equation and
boundary condition for
solving that deflection okay so overall
if we solve this thing
these three things together we should be
able to uh
obtain it obtain the solution so uh
we will go towards is towards the
solution for that
uh in the next video thank you very much